hi I'm Rafael Marte and this is Olivia
hi and we are professional tattoo we
were 30 or 28 in Manhattan on 6th Avenue
and I mean 28th Street so we're here
answering any questions through a live
feed
hosted by BuzzFeed and we're going to
also be reviewing tattoos so please send
them on over to us we'll have a chat
about it that will be very fun but first
we're gonna start a little bit with some
some thing about us so what was the
first thing you remember drawing all of
you
so I remember drawing Ninja Turtles when
I was a kid because I had a big brother
he was really into it that's what he was
drawing I was drawing what he was
drawing I remember when I was bored as a
child and I wanted to draw things and I
would ask my family members what I
should draw they would just tell me to
look for things in the house to draw it
was terrible and I suggest I remember my
grandmother had this little owl statue
that I sat there and drew just whatever
I could get my hands on kind of the time
nice that's really good I just started I
had a big coloring book like a really
really big one when I was a kid and I
went straight to the back pages the
empty pages and I would draw the Sun the
Sun perfect lemon Sun and it was like a
dinosaur book so dinosaur a coloring
book so I would throw some dinosaurs and
stuff in there but the first thing I
remember was just big drawings of the
Sun on that big empty newsprint paper
[Music]
Chantell mark call rawski has a question
I think I said that right hopefully I
didn't she has a question um have you
ever had anybody a customer angry with
you after you gave them a tattoo yeah
some people have a certain expectation
that may or may not be a realistic
certain things translate as tattoos
better than other things so as long as
you communicate with your client before
doing the tattoo some of that stuff can
be quieted a little bit beforehand yeah
I've also had people not that many but
I've had people with the same thing they
have a certain expectation of how they
want it to look beforehand
and there's just some things in tattoos
that you can't tattoo everything there's
there's limits we try to push them but
there's limits what's your earliest
memory of tattoos I remember my cousin
Karen when I was a kid in the Dominican
Republic she had a tattoo on her ankle
it was I feels like a woman it was the
figure of a woman or something and it
was a hand poke tattoo and okay and I
remember that when I was a kid that I
knew that that was a hand poked attitude
that was a feeling that I saw and stayed
in the back your life what about you it
really memories I mean my family they
didn't have any tattoos
I don't recall specific early memories
of tattoos being like enamored by them
or anything like that I think once I
started you know in high school I guess
I started paying closer attention to it
but early memories and I don't
yeah my cousin was the first one I I saw
tattoos as a kid but that was the first
one that I remember saying oh wow that's
that's what a tattoo like yeah it was
the first one I saw in person so that
made a profound effect on me have you
ever done on the crazy tattoo like a
forehead tattoo or anything I have never
done a forehead tattoo yeah I've never
mmm excuse me I've never done a forehead
tattoo I've never done a face tattoo of
any sort I've tattooed the head things
like that but never never directly on
the face I'm selective about those types
of tattoos so I have never tattooed
somebody like straight in the middle of
their forehead before yeah I tattooed
the sides of people's heads and it's
crept into forehead a little bit maybe
up here your parents have tattoos no my
parents didn't have tattoos my parents
are his witnesses and that's how I was
raised
so tattoos were not a part of my
lifestyle growing up what about your
parents
my folks do did not have tattoos I
actually just gave my mother her first
tattoo you about two years ago maybe she
got like a half sleeve no big deal she's
super tough yeah it was really cool it's
a fun experience and she wears it very
proudly so I was that stuff really neat
I don't think my pops will ever get one
he I just I don't think he'll ever
decide to he would only get it so I
could do it which is nice yeah yeah well
that actually brings us into our next
question which is your mom got a tattoo
after she was a full adult grown grown
woman and someone Kamiya the great is
asking should a 16 year old get a tattoo
with a parents
so New York State it is not legal
even with parental consent you must be
18 years old to get tattooed there are
other states that have different
restrictions on that but in New York you
must be 18 yes I remember getting my
first tattoo at 18 years old and it was
different for me because I was in a
tattoo shop
and I always saw tattoo so after I got
that tattoo I saw other cooler tattoos
that I was like man I should have done
that so I think if you're 16 years old
you could wait a little longer and see
if that's what you really really want to
live with forever that's definitely some
good advice
yeah so in my opinion I don't think at
16 year old should get a tattoo you're
gonna go through a lot of changes you
might like the cartoon that you're gonna
get tattooed on you when you're 16 but
when you're 18 you might grow out of it
you're still still developing yeah what
was your first tattoo Olivia my first
tattoo was a lotus flower on my wrist I
was 18 my brother took me and yeah I I
don't really love it anymore I've
actually gotten some laser treatment on
it but I'll probably just put a nicer
lotus flower right on top I did design
it though when I was in high school
nice stop I got were like twins I got my
eyes at I'm my first met two as well at
18 I'm also getting at laser removed not
because I don't like it I just want to
have my back clear four right one big
back that I don't have to make room or
compromise you know
[Music]
you draw Olivia yeah do you draw yeah
and how long did it take you to become
good
Amy's asking this question yeah we draw
every day it's really important to keep
practicing things like that it's the
best way to learn to figure out a style
that works for you um to become good I
mean it's subjective I've been tattooing
for seven years so I'm still I feel like
you just forever learn you have to
remain teachable throughout your entire
career so yeah you never want to
stagnate and think you know everything
and you're stuck because the whole world
is gonna keep moving forward I do draw
I've been drawing my whole life pretty
much and some people really really like
it and some people don't like it it's
really it's really good I think that I'm
good how did you get into tattooing so I
got into tattooing because when I was in
high school I stumbled upon an
apprenticeship through a job that I had
um I had a telemarketing job my manager
was full of tattoos and he told me hey
man you're always drawing when you're on
the phone you should go meet my tattoo
artists he's looking for an apprentice
Oh like I said my parents were you know
Jehovah's Witnesses so I didn't think
that they were gonna be cool with me
going to learn but they were and that's
how I started doing I started going to
the tattoo shop after school and in all
my free time
that's how I started learning to tattoo
and I loved it I stuck with it well got
you into it that's when I was working
just a red lyrium wage job and making
art forever and it was just a suggestion
made to me just to try you know that I
could maybe do that as a career so I
went out and put a portfolio together
got myself an apprenticeship and took
those means to start my career I was 19
so that's the cold wind 'red ami
wants to know what's the weirdest thing
someone has asked you it's the weirdest
thing I don't know I did a tiny little
llama once on this girl's butt cheek
that's kind of weird but also adorable I
also did like a poodle once I had a
unicorn it was like a poodle corn on the
integrals arm it was very small I guess
those are kind of weird and funny but
those those are the types of things that
make things fun for us and exciting yeah
so for me the weirdest thing that
someone asked was they wanted a stamp of
made in China because her nickname was
Barbie you know like there's stuff that
I don't like tattooing is there anything
that you just flat-out refuse to tattoo
and things technically aren't great as a
tattoo like a white tattoo or tattoos on
certain part of the body that just don't
hold up great over time I try and leave
those out so that when someone comes in
for a tattoo we know it's gonna look
great forever so those are the ones that
I will flat-out refused to do I don't
what myself to be attached to something
that I know is not gonna be great down
the line
[Music]
yeah that's i don't tattoo anything that
is like derogatory or anything that's
hateful
if yeah that's pretty much anything
hateful or derogatory yeah yeah gang
tattoos are a no go as well sometimes
you have to like read up on that a
little bit cuz these kids can be crafty
and you have to just dirt you don't want
to become that tattoo studio that does
that yeah for sure
uh Joanne would like to know how many
tattoos you have uh I don't know a
number because I have a lot of big
tattoos yeah so I would say I have most
of my body tattooed in front of my body
mostly tattooed and my back is mostly
free yeah but my thighs are mostly free
so I would say maybe fifty to sixty
percent of my body that's more than me
for sure I again I don't I haven't
counted in quite some time but yeah I
probably have closer to like thirty
percent of my body tattooed so I plan on
living for a really long time so I I
want to like take my time getting
tattoos so I can get tattooed for a long
time you guys watch it submit some of
your own tattoo photos so that we can
take a look at them and let you know
what we think yeah that's always fun do
you like this yeah so I don't have a
number I just have oh yeah I have a lot
yeah more to come and have you ever had
any crazy stories crazy client story um
I had a when I was an apprentice there
was this client of my mentor who was
probably thirty years my senior and he
wanted me to tattoo a butterfly
underneath his belt buckle which was
like a really sensitive spot to get a
tattoo for somebody as like shy and just
beginning for me to do a tattoo I was a
tough spot to get to I was fighting with
his belt the whole time it was
embarrassing and awful and I'd never
want to see that tattoo again but I
would say that was pretty wild that he
asked me to do that
yeah I haven't also not appropriate
story this lady came in she wanted a
pair of lips biting a chocolate-covered
strawberry and the juice was dripping
off the lips and it was going down
toward her vagina but the weirdest thing
about that whole situation was that she
brought her daughter who was like 18
years old and she's like 40-something
years old no judgment on the age it's
just that why do you bring your 18 year
old daughter as it was uncomfortable for
both me and her daughter and but we got
through it
she held my hand drew wants to know drew
CAD well did he take our classes in
school or before becoming an apprentice
yeah when I was in high school they had
to like pretty much invent some classes
for me because I had just run through as
many as I could when I was a senior I
didn't really take much academic classes
at all
they're mostly what are they called
I don't know when you take the classes
that you pick I took as many art classes
I could from ceramics to drawing and
painting and fashion illustration and
whatever they would offer me I was also
in IB art is an internal baccalaureate
it's like an internationally recognised
art class that's self-directed and you
get college credit for it that was
really cool that I've got really great
memories from that and I've taken some
classes at like a local art school on
Long Island where I'm from so
yeah yeah I've taken our classes ice
while I was learning how to tattoo I was
signed up at the Art Institute of Fort
Lauderdale mm-hmm but I spend too much
time in the tattoo in the tattoo studio
so I dropped out due to attendance but I
kept with it I take classes on my own at
the School of Visual Arts for example
they have continuing education courses
for adults and for anybody actually
who's interested in taking them and they
are phenomenal yeah because you're going
there and you're taking the class that
you actually want to learn yeah that
makes a big effect on your absorption of
that information and it's really fun you
know you meet other artists then you
never stop learning so it's always good
to to keep educating yourself should I
still do it I think it's important to
you have any like trendy tattoos that
you really like to do um so shiny
tattoos come in every day as walk-ins
which especially where we're located in
the proxy it's you Times Square we get a
lot of tourists who come through and
want to leave mark with little souvenir
often times you'll get people getting
like New York City skylines and things
like that sometimes it's an Apple to
represent New York which i think is
pretty cool there's I think there's a
little bit more creative license there
which I'm always looking for especially
with something that's a trend because it
it can get but if there's there's an
opportunity to take some artistic
license that's always so I think that's
something like that would be would be my
favorite trend right now I actually like
I like doing fine line things so for me
it's a it's a fun challenge to make it
as crisp as Times New Roman as I can
when I look at tattoo that I've done
that looks like a computer data that's
pretty cool because I mean you know I
just I just like the technical aspect of
it so people like to get dates that's
something that is it's fun for me to do
yeah I'm not a big fan of the infinity
symbol though yeah I'm glad that slowed
down a little bit I don't like doing it
because the people that are getting them
or jumping and they that's like you know
so don't look good yeah
lászló wants to know something a lot low
Zoli he asked have you ever tattooed any
private parts which addressed earlier no
I have not nor do I think I would I
don't need to it's not important that I
do it and so I just abstained for that
completely and nobody's asked me so
state well technically I have tattooed
over vaginas but I could say I've never
tattooed a penis before actually you
know what I have done
tattoos over myself mastectomy scars for
women who are survivors of breast cancer
so private not quite as private you know
free the nipple I guess but yeah so I've
helped women kind of reclaim their
bodies that way yeah that's nice yeah
that's that's pretty cool that I'll do
every day Oh have you ever made a
mistake tonight yep yep it happens for
sure yeah I think it's important to
remain humble in these situations and
things like that definitely happen but
three years of experience and making
adjustments to your work you know there
are tricks and things that we learn
along the way to kind of remedy anything
that might go wrong throughout a tattoo
sometimes the client will be on their
phone and they drop it and then they
reach for it or they're not considerate
of we're trying to shoot a moving target
and things like that happen and there
are things that you just can't account
for that you have to be able to be
adaptable on
yeah I mean I got to where I am making
mistakes here that but yeah I mean
you're the tattoo artists are not
perfect so yeah I've personally made
mistakes tattooing just like Olivia said
you always try to rectify it
you're freezing but you're sweating
do you remember when you're an
apprentice maybe tattooing somebody and
you throw your hood up and kind of like
create this barrier between you and your
client everybody you work with that was
that was a good time I'm glad I've
graduated from when I was first learning
how to tattoo when I was like still in
my apprenticeship I misspelled something
sure oh yeah and that was not pretty I
had to do one of my first cover ups
right that's a scary one that's why you
should always check your spelling people
yeah all the time
I triple check it it's annoying but I
don't care okay I don't care do you want
to fix it now or later right drew would
like to know if you have any
recommendations for aspiring tattoo
artists I would say yeah a lot of
recommendations you have to a really
know that you want to tattoo moved on
tattoo or don't get into tattooing
because it's popular and there's TV
shows nowadays and or you think that
you're gonna get rich off of it because
none of that is true this is a hard job
you could succeed greatly but you
it's not gonna be an overnight thing so
you gotta find somebody that you really
admire go get tattooed by then asking
questions get tattooed by as many good
people as you can but you have to find
an apprenticeship that's the first thing
to do is get an apprenticeship because
you're gonna learn all the right things
the right way instead of having to
unlearn things 15 years into your career
you know yeah I'd be doing it wrong the
whole time yeah it's really hard to turn
things around if you've learned bad
habits along the way and it's why it's
important to have a mentor to guide you
with the right tools to use to help you
put design together there are tattoo of
all and most importantly is to keep
yourself and your clients safe from
blood-borne pathogens which is something
we take pretty seriously at the studio
which you can only find inside of a
tattoo studio so I think that an
apprenticeship is first and foremost
yeah for sure
first gun apprenticeship and then get
tattooed and then and then don't rush
through the apprenticeship don't don't
like take an apprenticeship and then you
had a falling-out with the artist and
then now you're just I could open my own
tattoo shop now you're not gonna get
very far and a lot of people are not
gonna like you like she said earlier
there's a small community so you want to
do things the right way yeah we can be
snobby yeah for sure um do you ever tell
people that they're asking for a bad
tattoo
um I probably would be a little bit more
delicate than that but I try and guide
people into ideas that are a little bit
more unique or original or sometimes the
composition isn't gonna work the way
that they think or it's too much ideas
in a small area so you just try and make
adjustments that are best for the tattoo
and the longevity of the tattoo
everybody's got different ideas
some of them are better than others and
the best you can do is just navigate
through that so yeah yeah I always give
them my professional opinion people get
whatever they want I've learned over the
years that what I don't like is not
necessarily what they don't like so and
what they like is not necessary what I
like as long as I know that I'm putting
out a good quality solid tattoo at the
end of the day that's what I care about
um but yeah if it's a bad tattoo that's
gonna be in a bad spot it's not gonna
heal right the design is too complicated
too intricate or for many reasons I
collect you know what my professional
opinion is if you still say no I don't
care I still want this and I think it's
really really bad that it's not gonna be
good I won't do it I'll refuse to do it
but please send us your tattoos at this
link and we will review them shortly kg
would like to know have you ever had
anybody pass out on you yes it's not as
common as you know with piercings
happens but yeah people pass out with
tattoos it could be caused by you know
low blood sugar they didn't eat
breakfast they can just be really really
nervous or excited or anxious and be so
many things but no we're not just gonna
finish the tattoo on you while you pass
out not full-blown out all the close
calls really in seven years yeah no I
yeah I'm pretty lucky I guess keep juice
on hand you know yeah
you have sweetheart takes people right
out of that that feeling so fortunately
it's not a problem
yeah what is something you would never
say it oh it's hats what is um you
should never tell them that their work
is not worth what you know we think it
is it's our livelihood we take it very
seriously
nobody we work super hard up until the
moment that we get a client in the chair
so if there's anything in Seoul about
how we make our livelihood it kind of
sucks also like sometimes people flip
through a portfolio and they might see
something they don't understand and make
remark about how you know why would
anybody ever get this tattooed on them
it's not for that person necessarily
understand and those things hurt our
feelings
so is don't try to take because we're
the ones doing you might have been to
somebody else said those things
differently but everybody's different so
yeah I would just say be respectful and
you know if they give you a price that
you don't like or don't don't get all
insulted about it there's so many tattoo
artists that if you don't want to get
tattooed by that person there's no
reason to just be stupid and say
something nasty just because you don't
ever yeah let me do anything
rad Rob Wren
rad randomness that's random I wanted to
know where two tattoos hurt the most or
least everybody's a little bit different
with that but over my the field tests
that I've collected over the last seven
years the top of the foot doesn't feel
so great
I decided the head doesn't feel great
elbow you know you just tattooed the
side of a person's head earlier today
went well she sat pretty good she was
not loving every second of it but it was
a really fun tattoo to do so yeah that
that's how she sucks while you're
getting it but I felt like you know
healing that tattoo is pretty easy yeah
your hair starts growing out and like
pushes out all the stuff that you don't
want on there so the healing is pretty
easy for that but as far as easy spots
like a forearm anymore most places on
your arm are pretty okay right yeah I
think so
for me personally everybody's different
but the back of my knee was up there and
most painful um I think personally
anywhere that has tendons tend to hurt
more like anywhere Bend uh-huh wrist
I think wrist is excruciating Lee people
I don't have anything on my rear and
when I tattoo so many people on their
wrist yeah jaesi way Armstrong
wants to know if there's any advice we
can give to people who have dark or
brown skin that want to get attention
you can absolutely get a tattoo there
are certain colors that are gonna work
better than other colors on certain
complexions a basic rule for that is you
wouldn't want to attach you a color
that's lighter than the natural skin
tone on that person so it's going to
natural it's going to mix with your
natural skin tone and then it's going to
change the color of the tattoo so if
somebody's a bit darker and they want
like a lavender on them it's not going
to look quite as as light and pastel as
it would on somebody on fair skin so you
just want to be careful about the
selection colors say that you choose
black and gray is great also yeah I
agree with that
and I also think maybe going bigger
is better especially if you want
something with a lot of detail because
you'll see it more clearly
yeah like Olivia said anybody can get a
tattoo just as long as this is the right
image you know you can't get something
super delicate or you know just like a
white tattoo or something like she said
that's darker than your skin tone like
yellow won't really show on dark people
because you know your skin's are any
darker than yellow so yeah that's just
it just makes sense what do you what do
you think about matching tattoos um I
don't have any matching tattoos with
anyone you know I know a lot of people I
have matching tattoos that I've gotten
covered up mm-hmm so mm-hmm that's a
tough question um I don't think it's a
bad idea if you have somebody that you
want to get a matching tattoo with and
it's a bonding experience that's what
life is all about yeah you gotta get it
there you do with it later you either
live with it as a good reminder of hey
listen don't [ __ ] do this again or
you know maybe it'll remind you of
something that you learned
I think matching tattoos are alright um
I think that getting a piece of media
like an image is more appropriate than
getting a name necessarily because even
the image is a little bit more cryptic
even if the only issue with matching
tattoos is if you have a falling out
with that person or that's always the
the curse as they say so if you've got a
piece of media you could still be
attached to what that represented even
with that person or without so I think
that's a safer way to go about a
matching tattoos with an image than a
name yeah for sure that's a really smart
you don't want them
be like Oh who's that you know yeah it's
just gonna bring back open up the
floodgates mm-hm
chicken tender no it's the most restful
tattoo we have to do would you like to
go first
so stressful tattoo that's because it's
always stressful to some degree mhm
you're trying to do the best job that
you can but the most stressful tattoos
for me are something that has a lot of
information and the stencil stencil is
what you put on and that's the guideline
that we as tattoo artists follow oh when
the stencil is just not holding up right
it doesn't matter what it is that's the
most stressful part of a tattoo so if
you want to know a stressful image I
would say like or like a very intricate
mendala
yeah that would be pretty stressful for
me what about you I do not find mandalas
stressful that's something that I enjoy
doing
so things that are stressful to tattoo
yeah like your stencil is really
important that I redraw things a hundred
times to make sure my stencils exactly
where I wanted to be at so I don't have
to think so much while I'm while I'm
tattooing I want the thought to be
already done with the design and for me
just like pay attention to making clean
lines so yeah stressful when that
doesn't work out and sometimes clients
can make it so that you you know you
can't read them sometimes it's hard to
meet a client and decide whether they're
like feeling yeah you know you want your
client to be like a hundred percent
confident with the design that you're
putting together so sometimes people can
be you know difficult to read and in
that case it can cause for a stressful
tattoo and they can leave very very
happy and you know yeah you just never
know I got a really good point sometimes
when people are so
committed to the image the reference
image that they may have brought in for
you to base the tattoo off of and you're
designing something custom for them and
then they're like well but this doesn't
match up with this and especially when
it's a picture of another tattoo that
they bring we're not gonna copy that
tattoo that other person's tattoo and
then put it on you so we're gonna make
it unique for you or take that concept
and make something cool for you
so sometimes it's stressful when someone
really is set on getting that image the
way that they brought it in mm-hmm when
you've already gone through that process
so hey listen I'm gonna do this for you
there's gonna be some changes so that
this person doesn't feel like you know
that they got there they may have gotten
that tattoo custom done for them so you
don't want to rip off somebody's idea
just like you don't want somebody you
know taking your tattoo so sometimes
when people are very very specific on
the image if it comes from another
tattoo image that might be a little bit
stressful for me because I like to still
have artistic freedom I agree Braz Matt
wants to give a touch of yourself I have
nothing I'm particularly proud of is a
long time ago when I was an apprentice
my mentor felt like it was really
important for me to talk to myself and I
don't disagree I think it's important
for you to it's like a very valuable
learning experience as far as like
getting a feel for things what it feels
like when you're tattooing somebody else
things like that they're on me and
they'll be there for a long time and
that's just that it is they they're not
great yeah out of convenience cuz when I
was learning how to tattoo
I didn't want to find somebody in and go
through the whole process
hey let me try this one right I just did
it on myself and that took a lot of
pressure off because if I did mess up on
myself right who's gonna care you get to
like see exactly how it heals and
everything else is why you have the it's
so many so many pros
yeah I've touch with myself it sucks
personally when I get focused on
something that kind of like drains out
the pain or whatever but yeah it's to
yourself isn't the most alright it's
hard to like impose that pain upon your
like I flicked that pain upon yourself -
you're like all ease up a little bit but
that's not how it works
yeah the only one who knew it I had to
tattoo myself several times cake wants
to know um do you think that doctors are
a good idea um so they that's a thing
that exists or at their UV light
sensitive pigments I don't personally do
them I think even if they have all this
great flashiness when you first do them
they don't hold up over time that that
effect is going to get lost
oftentimes those pigments have their
like more of a pastel kind of color so
even on their own they don't they don't
look like much and I'm not sure exactly
what is in there to make it do that but
I don't like it yeah I'm not a big fan
of them for all those reasons yeah and
you can only see those tattoos when
you're under a blacklight anyway yeah
it's a novelty like if you're at a party
and I really want somebody's at a party
what do they care that you have an
invisible to everybody could see right
we're gonna move on to reviewing your
tattoos so
let's do some types of reviews sure so
we this first one we have here is an
artichoke which I am partial to as I
also have an artichoke I see that you
look at it every day I like that
subject matter I think it looks great
it's a very well saturated tattoo I
think we even have the same colors in
here a little bit but yeah that's a
solid tattoo that's not going anywhere
anytime fast and that I think it looks
great yeah that's what looks really nice
we said look very well saturated it
looks crisp and clean or just look like
they knew what they were doing for sure
and that spot doesn't look very painful
you think that's a really long time to
do that um probably not anything too
crazy it's probably about this big maybe
but depends on how the how fast the
tattooer worked its own oh it's a nice
one oh beetles action there we got a
yellow submarine tattoo that's cool I
don't how to get in there there we go
this looks pretty cool it looks like the
tattoos already healing right yeah for
sure so that looks pretty good it healed
up great yeah that's how colors in there
uh-huh
that color is very solid huh the lines
are nice and clean the imagery is really
nice yeah I like the Beatles me too it's
pretty cool yeah that looks great um
let's see if there's something else we
are going to remind you to stay tuned
because we're gonna give you some advice
on people getting their first tattoo
coming up there it is
okay different page yes so here we have
a giant bear some arrows going through
it right over the kneecap little yeah
tattoo place maze boom yeah that's
really nice I think for everyone
involved that the client and the artist
probably getting that as solid as it is
it's a lot of work yeah props that you
could tell how swollen that yeah yeah
and yeah that tattoo looks really good
I like like traditional style tattoos
you know this is not like a full-on
traditional but it looks nice yeah
that's gonna last for a long time it's
gonna hold up great yeah that must have
taken probably a few sessions they
probably got it outlined and then
colored in maybe maybe so that's nice
that's a nice tattoo you have a like an
ornamental filigree kind of lotus flower
dot work with a compass there's a lot
going on this tattoo but it looks really
nice it's super clean it looks like it's
healed up pretty well that's a healed
picture um so yeah it looks good yeah
there's a lot of detail in that tattoo
mm-hmm and that's not the most easy spot
to get tattooed in so I give that girl
props
oh that's really cute that's really nice
tattoo we have a dog portrait here it's
a little illustrative it's not quite
realistic with some flowers and some
ornamental beading and things that's a
really nice tattoo yeah it is mm-hmm I
love Pet tattoos you have some I have
some myself looks really nice very solid
the black was very well saturated and
the lines were really clean which is
always what I look for and next we have
a watch with an orange rose yeah and
some cherry blossoms it looks like it's
on a person's thigh and that color it
looks so good it really is in there yeah
the color is very solid it's it's not
easy to get that solid color packing
especially with like a lack of shading
or anything like that there's like
there's no other they would Stuber solid
yeah yeah you know really good job
either way here's a nice kind of like
opposites tattoo yeah the skull of a
horse hanging off some branches with
some crystals and then you have a live
horse on the other calf and they're
facing each other and it has like a live
stuff around it's has flowers cool it's
a cool take on like such a classic idea
of like things that are opposite whether
it's live and dead or like I don't know
I just I think it's fun to see it done
play with the horses and the flowers and
everything it's really cool yeah this
this image really stands out to me I
really like it nice balance
in the subject ooh
alien tattoo an abduction this is a
triangle within a triangle and inside
that triangle is a spaceship in the
forest hovering above the forest it's
very simple and I like the image tattoo
wise I feel like the lines could be
maybe a little bit more solid maybe a
little bit more clean but it's very
readable exactly how it is you see the
trees you see the overall shapes and
there's no question oh I wonder if
they're gonna fill in the Triangle in
black or something somebody a lot of
really great tattoos in here yeah
somebody sent in a picture of her
sternum tattoo and it's flowers or it's
one flower right yeah with leaves and
branches come around and this tattoo is
so clean yeah it looks great that's a
tough spot to get a tattoo it's a tough
spot to do a tattoo so when it comes out
nice and clean like that that's what you
hope for for sure it's a cool palette
also yeah it's a limited color yeah I
like the Merman color seamless muted
colors do we have work for tattoo mm-hmm
I don't know who this person is so it
might be somebody that the wearer knows
maybe a relative or something yeah I was
gonna say it looks it looks like Taylor
Swift to me I don't
okay so since I couldn't tell it was
Taylor Swift I'd say there's a little
bit of room for improvement because it
looks a little washing
but portraits are tough because if it's
not a celebrity and you don't know who
the person is you know you it's hard to
say whether it's an effective portrait
or not but I I could tell this Taylor
Swift
oh this tattoo I love looks like
something you would do
yeah this is a dust card it looks like
and it's a skeleton it's a skeleton
without the cloak so I guess it's just a
skeleton but it has the what's called a
sickle right yeah I think that's called
the sickle and it's pretty cool it's
very detailed I like doing these types
of images and only thing I could say is
that it should have been a little bit
bigger for the amount of detail that it
has if it would have been bigger I would
have done all day on it yeah yeah I see
it now yeah yeah it's nice any thing you
would have done differently I think the
size is definitely a good point that you
made looks like it was just kind of sat
right in there in the forearm any bigger
it would have wrapped around it so maybe
if the placement were a little bit
different you'd be able to make it a
little bit larger and that may have been
would have made for an a more effective
tattoo cool what does this tattoo this
is our Lady of Guadalupe thanks again I
think the placement works well with it
because it's more narrow so it fits the
compass card on your body such as your
forearm yeah some of those flames curve
a little bit but that's fine because
it's not the focal point of the piece
but I think there's a good balance
between color and black shading and skin
tone in there I think that works yeah um
this is my my personal favorite tattoo
but it's definitely solid I just like
other types of imagery that's right but
yeah I mean it was it definitely healed
really well on that person for sure the
colors in there
and the lines are solid so overall I
would have just done different it's for
that for the quite a little bit that's
all oh we don't have a scorpion
you can't scroll down either there's
nothing left I could see the Sun from
this work take it away
it was there for a second okay we're all
the way down you know well there's
supposed to be a scorpion scorpion
oh we have a rose yeah we talked about
this tiny rose
yeah we can't scroll down any further so
anyway I can see part of this Rose
Tattoo oh there it is how did you do
that yeah again it's a little bit small
and the photo creates a reflection on
the tattoo so it's hard to see part of
it yeah but it's a nice classic design
just the silhouette of the rose I think
they're really cool and they generally
you know as long as the line work is
there you can tell what it is forever
yeah even if the colors viewed a little
bit or what-have-you
the line works strong you'll be able to
tell what the images yeah that rose I
agree with you should have been a bit
bigger it was nice and dark which is
good
but yeah just a little bit bigger
sometimes it's it's always better to go
a little bit bigger with your tattoos
especially if you want something that's
build and that's important to you take
your tattoo artists advice and bigger
the better
we are going to be part of it we have
the top of penny wise his head penny
wise is loading this looks kind of like
a trash polka style maybe mm-hmm her
just oh there it is okay cool so cool
penny wise I can tell whoever did that
had a good time making it yeah for sure
that that comes across in the image and
it was really well done
- it looks like a little like caricature
yeah the lines are nice and crisp the
color is nice and solid in there I
really like this tattoo yeah do you have
any movie tattoos on their movie tattoos
no oh is that Calcifer from Stu Miyazaki
school me girl think it's that's an
anime oh ah Howl's Moving Castle I think
it's Calcifer this so it reminds me of
if pretty sure yeah it's a cute tattoo
you there fun cool I like this tattoo I
don't know what character it is but it's
a little flame and it looks very
different on here than it does in the
movie obviously this is more of like a
watercolor style and then in the movie
it's anime style is it tattoo a like
this because what it is yes the anime
yes it's a feel-good tattoo yeah yeah
and color saturation is really really
well yeah what do you what do you think
about watercolor tattoos
people either love them or hate them um
I don't really love doing them I feel
like it's kind of as long as things are
holding up over time it's important for
me personally to put line work in things
and hold a shape together because when
you get as abstract as watercolor can
get sometimes those two things need to
go together in order to make an
effective tattoo you like doing them oh
right yeah I like blending the colors
but I really agree with you on the on
the border yeah having a crisp edge yeah
I I like to call them color splatter
touches because I don't I I make it look
like it's yeah like it actually like ink
splatters on the skin instead of just
washes I just wonder like what that
shape is gonna look like and in five or
ten years and I feel like some people
get a tattoo because they know it's
gonna look good when they leave the shop
but uh you gotta look down the line
because you're gonna have it for life
you know it's awesome to do if you have
a tattoo
go back to your tattoo artists so they
can see your tattoo over time we love
that spent holidays there's a big
controversy on social media talking
about people editing their photos to
make their tattoos look better so it's
always nice if you have a tattoo and you
get along with the artist go back and
say hey check this out
hold up nicely next we have a tattoo
that is an outline of a country
I cannot tell what country it is it was
parents and it looks like two parrots
are flying next to each other in here
and yeah this tattoo looks just like
it's not small it's on somebody red yeah
so it's fairly big and it's pretty cool
you can tell that this tattoo has a lot
of emotional or a lot of significance to
that person sure I like that
not every tattoo has to be a crazy
drawing
sometimes you just want things to look
cool you like yeah exactly
here's some roses roses cool I
personally like to shade you know so but
this tattoos has very nice solid lines I
would just would have shaded it yeah I
mean it's possible they they might get
another session in there what-have-you
but I agree I think adding more value
and contrast to a piece is important so
yeah yeah this tattoos not bad by any
means I just have a different taste I'm
also just that y'all know when we're
finished with this we're gonna be
answering some questions for first-time
clients who have never been tattooed you
might have some reservations or
what-have-you about entering a tattoos
to you it can be intimidating so we're
gonna help you walk walk you through
that
yeah next tattoo it's the world map with
a big compass over the world map mm-hmm
and some almost like filigree yeah it
kind of reminds me of like a fractal
almost yes yeah and there's an anchor in
there too yeah there's a lot in this
image
[Music]
it's pretty solid yeah I personally the
color looks amazing in this picture so I
wouldn't change anything of this tattoo
yeah yeah I think there's a lot of stuff
in it but it's not like it's not your
stuff is in there it's big enough um
yeah I think it works yeah there's some
people sometimes that they want too much
stuff right in a small area yeah and
they want it facing them which is
nothing but anytime somebody asked me
for a tattoo that's gonna be facing them
yeah I always tell him it's gonna
probably look crooked or worked when you
go to show someone and you twist your
wrist yeah yeah I agree I usually try
and advise people as well just because
it's kind of like a trendy thing now and
to have your tattoos facing you but if
you add another tattoo on top of it that
one will probably face outward so yeah
you don't want a whole sleeve of tattoos
that are upside down yeah so I usually
try and have people think down the line
um so what's some practical advice you
give people some first-time um I think
it's important for you to do some
research know exactly what you want to
get and then speak with a professional
about it seek out the artist that you
think is going to do the job that you
can require and to remain open-minded
with that artist because even though you
came in knowing exactly what you wanted
sometimes things need to be amended to
make the tattoo successful Yeah right
that's the hope that for sure and then
also I would say if you have a budget
don't compromise your tattoo because of
your budget because you could always
save more money
but you once that tattoos there it's
gonna be a lot more difficult to deal
with
or if you know don't just don't
compromise on what you want to get just
because you want to get it now a lot of
people are very impulsive and they just
wanted to get a tattoo today which I
understand that I've had that feeling
before huh but you know you if you have
tattoos you know that they're gonna be
there right
you know sometimes I have tattoos and I
don't I don't even remember because you
know like I got them and yeah it's super
important I was looking at it every day
but you're having them for a few years
it's like oh yeah I forgot to have that
one I think I think the same goes for
placement like people can get concerned
about the pain and so you don't want to
compromise where you put the tattoo for
the amount of pain which brings the next
question when you're preparing for the
pain every every tattoos gonna hurt a
little bit
some are gonna hurt a little bit more
than others it's really like the shock
in the beginning that's the worst part
once you settle into the idea it doesn't
hurt quite so bad and it's most always
worse in your head than it is when
you're actually getting it yeah I would
say have you know eat before mm-hmm you
couldn't get tattooed don't do it on the
sonic and the night before you get
that's we rust you know that might seem
frivolous to some people but it actually
does come into account you come in
exhausted or in a bad mood or whatever
and that's gonna affect how you sit for
your touch mm-hmm
yeah we can't have any fidgety people it
makes it tough for everybody
yeah which leads us into our next
question is people how much should you
tip at a tours
it's never expected by any means but
it's definitely a very generous thing
you can do and put a lot of work into
the tattoo before the actual biller
billable hours start so whatever you
feel will show your gratitude to the
artist and the job that they did for you
I think is is how much you should take
them yeah there is no specific number
whatever you feel is good is fine with
me
I personally make a decent living I
cannot complain it also anything extra
is always appreciated exactly and it's
always even more than the money it's
just nice to to see somebody so happy
that they're just giving you something
extra right even if it's not money some
people took gifts Rachel is always cool
you know I had a client make me a felt
giraffe once it was adorable and I miss
her as well but yeah yeah that's better
for you to have a tattoo in mine or is
it better for you to work it work out
the design with your artist what do you
think is better to just come in with
here this is what I want so I fall for a
new client to come in with maybe more
than one reference same of what they
like or what they don't like about it
and I can customize something for them
directly it's up to the client what they
want and I'm willing to make whatever
alterations that they see fit but a
little bit of both you know an
open-mindedness from their end and then
my willingness to work with their idea
is is a good compromise I think it's a
healthy compromise in the relationship
yeah I always think it's good to have
reference because it's a starting point
yeah a lot of people sometimes say oh I
just do whatever you want which is like
the artists dream until a few people ask
you that question and then you do what
you want and then it's the total
opposite what they wanted so yeah just
conversing with your artist is always
the best thing you always gonna get the
best work from someone when you
collaborate and their ideas kind of come
out organically instead of you telling
them okay this is exactly what I want
because you'reyou're sticking them in a
box that you know they might not go out
of because they don't know if you're
gonna even why would they spend the time
doing that right right
Ignacio Lopez has a question how do I
know if the artist is a good or
professional tattoo artist there's a lot
of signs yeah a professional tattoo
artist is going to work inside of a
tattoo studio mm-hmm a professional
tattoo artist is going to give you as a
client the respect to talk to you about
your ideas it's not gonna be like you
know dismissive of you mm-hmm even if
it's somebody famous like there's a lot
of people that are famous but they still
give you the respect that sure
absolutely
to tell if somebody is good I mean you
just want to look for the style make
sure their lines are nice and clean I
think that you know you wouldn't go to a
portrait artist for a traditional style
tattoo and you wouldn't go to a
traditional artist for a portrait style
tattoo so you just want to find the
right person who does a good work yeah
there's another question what is the
biggest misconception about tats Wars Oh
conception
well then why don't you jump off well I
think that people think that tattoo
artists aren't smart people because you
have tattoos fair enough
they think that you're a lower class
person yeah which is really wrong a lot
of tattoo artists are very educated a
lot of people educate themselves you
don't necessarily have to have a college
degree to be educated so you know a book
by it's cover I think also a lot of
people's introduction to tattooers in
general is in their living room when
they're watching TV shows that are based
around tattoo artists
we're not rockstars we go home every
night and play with our cats and go to
bed at a reasonable hour cuz you got
work in the morning and you know it's
not just chaos and drama and things like
that all the time we like have very
personal regular lives outside of just
having a super-rad job yeah normal
people we just make our jobs yeah we
think it's kind of rare I think that was
our last question
yeah thank you everybody for submitting
your questions yeah make sure you
subscribe scribe the video thank you
[Music]
you